chris is in california hi Chris how are
you hi miss Rawnsley thank you for
taking my call sure um I about three
weeks ago I found you on YouTube and I'd
kind of you know my husband I have hit
the ground running I got your blood
somebody makeover and I'm kind of
reading through that I am currently
working a full-time job my husband like
three part-time jobs and we have two
little ones my question is do you
suggest I get a part-time job as well to
kind of help get the debt lowered faster
or should I change my w-4 because I do
get a pretty large tax return at the end
of the year those are independent
questions you should change your w-4
period automatically that causes nothing
but a little bit effort because if you
get a tax refund all that means is you
paid that much too much in taxes and
they give it back to you with no
interest after you left it up there all
year okay Santa Claus doesn't live in DC
matter of fact the antithesis of Santa
Claus lives in DC the paradox officers
okay
anyway now back to the other thing what
do you make at your full-time job I make
about thirty two thousand a year and why
does your husband not have a career he
is trying to start up his own business
so what it's been a few his own business
his own massage therapy business okay
why is he having trouble doing that it's
very competitive out here where we live
there's a lot of companies that do it
too a lot of independent contractors so
it's been a little bit hard that has
been kind of what has kept us afloat
because that that does bring the most
cash in from his part yeah I want him to
here's my guess on that the reason I
asked that is I suspected something like
that was in the offing and I think the
best probability of you guys adding
substantial income to your household is
you working yet another job it's him
getting this business working and he's a
better massage therapist than he is
marketer yeah and that's not unusual by
the way there's nothing wrong with that
that means he's good at his craft right
but he needs to learn to sell and
promote himself and develop some
marketing techniques and so I want him
reading articles by other massage
therapists and people in the personal
training business of how they grow their
clientele
I want him reading books and articles at
least an hour and a half a day starting
today he needs to learn how to sell
himself and sell that service and build
clientele and get referrals of
everybody's friends that he already is
doing their massage therapy right mm-hmm
and he's not doing that he goes in does
the job collect some money walks back
out he has tried in the past he's you
know done social media has done what
kind of promotions if you refer I gave
you a free you know hour and you kid the
second one and doesn't do it anymore he
does it on occasion he has to sell he's
not good at that he's got to work on
that because that's gonna make your
family more money than the two of you
put together doing the stuff you're
doing now he can make 50 or 60 a year
doing that if he builds us up more but
he's gonna forget his button gear and
learn how to sell himself and that's
what I'm saying he's gonna start reading
and learning I'll do that I'm gonna send
you a copy of the book on tray
leadership if you took a part-time job
what would you be making maybe 40 it
wouldn't be that much because it would
this be part-time and that shows eight
thousand dollars a year right and you'll
be working how many days maybe three
days three four days now if he worked
that many days he'd make three times
that yeah we can't get him in gear
that's a better answer than putting you
out there you guys are not afraid of
work you just got to get you working
smarter hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy of my book on tray leadership for
him on running his biz
okay and it'll help you with that it's
how we grew our business the marketing
himself that's the key here